welcome to campus we're based in the
heart of silicon roundabout just a block
away from the old street roundabout
where there's the largest concentration
of startups in East London let me show
you around in the first year alone we
hosted more than 850 event attracting
60,000 people to campus and at this
point we had more than 100,000 people
for events alone so we're now in the
lower ground floor of campus the cafe
and this is where a lot of the
serendipity happens the people behind me
are all intrapreneurs they came here to
work on their ideas and develop them
into a product launch it and hopefully
grow and make money out of it right
around the corner we have what we call
the campus mobile lab offering
entrepreneurs working on mobile product
a chance test their applications and try
their absence various tablets and
devices seeing that it works well and
doing user testing right behind me it's
the campus message board we clear it
once a week and then 48 hours later
usually looks something like this
welcome to tech hub this is one of the
two co-working floors of campus in the
past you used to rent your own office
connected to the internet by printers
and today you can simply rent a desk and
for a very low cost you're in business
and surrounded by the rest of the tech
community the walls are made of idea
paint letting anyone scribble their plan
on getting users or capturing a market
this is what startups are all about
visiting campus and want to work on your
pitch not a problem anyone can enter the
campus cam booth and reporter 60 second
pitch how can I dig up campus more than
he's already hit the center for a trip a
nurse in London
so campus is much more than just
workspace or office babe we hope the
tweet campus we can create the
environment to learn network and grow
your startup wherever you are